Hello everyone, this is Jin with next
level commander. I built a deck. I
played with it a few nights actually.
I even made a video about it, but even
now I can't say I know exactly how this
deck works. Yeah, this is probably the
most irresponsible video I'll ever make.
But yeah, I'm just going to throw this
out there and see the world burn. So,
I'm making this video copying the deck
at $49 so you all can test it for me and
tell me how it works. Well, to be fair,
I can explain individual cards like what
what they do. But the problem is when
they meet each other. Invited by this
guy. There are just so many overlapping
interactions that that every time I'm
about to make a sick sequence of plays,
I discover two more that are better. And
my play group is starting to lose
patience. So, what does this actually
do? Are you almost done? I want to go
home. But it's important to remember
that we cannot afford to lose our
friends. At least not until we've
collected enough testing for this deck.
So, yeah, I'm crowd sourcing this to
you. Uh, why don't we give it a try?
Well, let's try a few test scenarios to
see if you are at least more competent
than I am. But before that, we need to
introduce our commander deck Faden. When
Dack Faden enters, you reveal three
creatures from your library. You get
their ETB triggers and then you choose
an opponent to give them to and the
creatures are golded. Now, a few
important things that took me a while to
figure out. The first one is that you
get the ETB triggers despite donating
the creatures. So, no, you cannot use it
to world eater an opponent. But you do
get all the sweet ETB triggers which is
much more important. And the second much
more fringe ruling is that when
creatures ETB from Dack Faden's ability,
if they have a targeted ETB ability, you
don't choose the targets just yet. The
Dack Faden ability resolves first, all
the creatures are donated to the
opponents of your choice, then the ETB
triggers are put on the stack and that's
when you select the targets. And you
will see why this is relevant. Now, time
for the puzzles. Scenario one. Let's
start simple. This is the board. The
highlighted cards are owned by us, and
these three creatures just entered from
our deck trigger. What's the line?
Assuming there's nothing in the
graveyard. Just imagine how long is it
going to take before you even make a
play in this scenario. Oh, ain't nobody
got time for that. We're moving on to
scenario B. This one I actually
encountered during a game. I forgot to
highlight the creatures, but the white
creatures are owned by us, all of them.
I think it was turn seven or eight, I
can't remember, but but this was the
Dack Fayden pile, and from this I won
the game after about 15 minutes of
thinking. So, yeah, here are the board
states. The opponent's creatures don't
really matter. It's all about how we are
looping and recycling our creatures.
And finally, this board.
Yep. Here is the Dack Fayden pile, and
oh, yeah, I I I forgot to mention that I
don't have answers to these, especially
not this one.
Do I have an infinite combo? Is the game
over? I have no idea. I I did warn you
this video has zero accountability. For
the most part, you are on your own, but
I do want to talk a little bit about how
I came to this deck. Cuz you know, Dack
Fayden is broken. And but you go through
this phase where you see the creature,
you're like, "Wow, this is I can do all
these clever tricks. Yeah, I can do
this, and oh, yeah, this just wins on
the spot." Yeah, it's like when I
thought I discovered the hidden gems of
Witherbloom and the Green Goblin. But
this is such a sweet concept though.
It's It just looks so much fun, and I
wanted to build it. So then, naturally,
the solution is to go budget. Just to
play Dack Fayden and blink him a bunch
of times. Seems simple enough. You don't
even need Homeward Path, that's like
$17. Because your opponents will kill
each other with your creatures, and when
they do, the the dead player will return
all of their borrowed creatures to you
because they actually entered the
battlefield under your control. That
seems simple enough until I looked at
the creatures. Turns out white doesn't
have a lot of great creatures to donate.
And because so many of them have
keywords like lifelink, vigilance, you
don't want that. And also, you don't
want any activated or triggered
abilities that they can benefit from.
front. with the budget limitation, it
actually limits our choices by quite a
bit. And that was until I realized the
interactions we can do with these
Banisher Priest effects. They can be
used as soft removal when you exile
opponent's creatures. Yeah, imagine if I
exile Alex's commander and give it to
Ross and exile Ross's commander and give
it to Alex. Now, they don't want to
block with these cards anymore. Another
use for these is they can reset the
bigger creatures we donate, exiling
them, and they will return under our
control because we are the owner. And
finally, a few of these can be used to
blink Dak Fayden. Not Banisher Priest
though. How these creatures work is when
they enter, the donation happens, and
then their abilities are put on the
stack. So, with Banisher Priest, I can
choose for it to exile itself because
now it is controlled by my opponent. So,
then, when that happens, it blinks
itself and returns itself to my side of
the battlefield, which then you can use
to exile something on on the opponent's
side. And this is as much as I can tell
you. And how does Fiend Hunter work?
Well, I'll have you know that I've just
been blocked by my local judge, so
you're going to have to ask yours and
let me know. I also have a few of these
self-blink creatures. These are here
specifically to reset our commander for
another goal. Now, keep in mind, these
cannot exile other creatures that were
drawn from the same trigger. Because
once again, the creatures are donated,
and then this exile trigger is put on
the stack. And also, we have a few blink
spells to reset Dak Fayden at instant
speed. Holding one of these in hand with
an interlocked board like this, your
decision tree probably have hundreds of
branches. And if you made it this far
into the video, that's the kind of
scenario you live for, isn't it? Okay,
now, moving on to the actual creatures,
the fun stuff. We do have plenty of room
for that. Actually, in this deck, I
don't think it matters too much how many
creatures you play. It could be 10, 20,
30. I'm currently doing 16 blink
creatures and 16 value creatures, but
you can definitely cut down on that. And
for these creatures, once again, I
prioritized ones with solid ETB effects,
and I tried to avoid keywords like
lifelink and vigilance because I still
want my opponents to be beating each
other up. So, yeah, a lot of these ETB
removal triggers are excellent. And for
some of the more interesting effects,
for example, we have Soul of Eternity.
With the the quantity of creature
removals, even temporary ones, there's a
really high chance that we can help one
opponent force it through into another
opponent. Not to mention these tappers,
these are excellent. Because with
permanent gold effects, the last thing
you want is the creatures canceling each
other out via combat. And by timing
these tappers right, your opponents will
never get a chance to block with the
golded creatures. Sandstone Oracle is
excellent. We are very desperate for
card draw. The moment this comes down,
I'm blinking it over and over again.
Also, Salvation Clauses. This is one of
the hardest hitters you can donate.
Although you have to be careful giving
this to someone with a massive board
state that is not sponsored by you. Do
not do that. It will backfire. But when
it does, it's okay because you have
Resolute Archangel. This card is nuts.
Hopefully you don't flip it too early.
In the late game, this is like the
single card you want to see the most.
Okay, those are the donatable creatures.
Again, these slots are super flexible.
You can play pretty much whatever you
want. Experiment, try different things.
I do think ETBs are the best because of
the flickering shenanigans, but if you
find that to be too oppressive, you can
just play dumb beaters. The deck will
still work. Okay, now for pieces that
smooth out the deck. Of course, ramp, we
need lots of ramp. Dark Confidant is our
number one game plan, not close. But if
he gets shut down, like countered or
turned into a moon, the average mana
value of our deck is like five or six.
So you do need them. Do keep in mind you
want to avoid playing creatures for
anything else aside from your core game
plan, so you can be more consistent with
your hits. Another utility I found to be
really useful for smoothing the deck out
is looters. Yeah, these are not super
efficient, but because we can't afford
things like Scroll Rack, being able to
dump our big creatures to loot into ramp
or blink spells, it turned out to be
really useful when I played the deck.
And finally, I have a few end game
pieces. Honestly, I don't know how much
I need these because I feel like the
core of the deck can already close the
games pretty aggressively. But a lot of
these are really fun, like Sudden
Salvation. Yeah, when your creatures die
from combat or board wipe, just get them
back. Same with Storm of Souls, you get
everything back. You can they can exile
each other and reset the power and
toughness if you want. Same thing for
Rally the Ancestors. This one does exile
the creatures, but I've just got a
feeling you might be able to get around
that, maybe? Probably not. You are a
fair magic player. The Eagles are
coming. This card is made for this deck.
It's brilliant. And of course, perch
protection. Time this card right, and we
win the game. So, there you have the
deck. The land base is nothing too
special. We don't have a lot of budget
for that, but we do have these that can
remove our own creatures, so we can free
Dak Fayden at instant speed. And that's
the entire deck. I I'm not going to talk
much about how the deck works, cuz
honestly, I barely know it myself.
Hopefully, it's not too oppressive, not
hopefully not too many combos in the
deck. There's probably some. I do have
to say though, make sure you are very
familiar with how the stack works, with
the decision trees, maybe practice a bit
by yourself, because you will end up
with massive, massive decision trees.
Sometimes you will have to plan several
steps ahead, which can be extremely
difficult with, you know, interactions
and with how things get removed and how
things come back. I think this deck is
suited for the most experienced players.
Unless you have the most helpful, the
most tolerant playgroup, in which case,
congratulations. And that's it, Dak
Fayden, the helping hand. For this
video, I'm not going to announce
giveaway winners, but we will continue
to have another giveaway. Once again,
the same rules. You can check the video
description, but for this video, I want
to be a bit more lax with the card
recommendations. Yeah, if you try the
deck, if you, you know, give me some
feedback on how the deck works, of
course, you get extra entries into the
giveaway. That's exactly what I need.
You know, the different plays and
different interactions you've
discovered. But yeah, thank you so much
for watching all the way till the end.
If you're interested, check out my
sponsor Kakapopo TCG. They have
excellent products. Use my code levels
for a 5% discount. And that's all. I
will see you later.